I don't want anybody to feel like they
can't
go to an airport Kentucky Fried Chicken
which to me is what's left of this
country
what's left of this country if you were
not insanely wealthy is in the Miami
Airport there's a Kentucky Fried Chicken
and there's a Pizza Hut right next to it
and the Pizza Hut the pizzas have been
left under the warmer for so long that
the cheese is all browned and it's like
a scab it's like skin when the woman
cuts it she's cutting through the skin
of a once great Empire and next to it
there are people that are eating chicken
sandwiches before they get on a flight
before it's the last thing they remember
of America before they go back to Santo
Domingo or wherever they're going they
take they get chick frat greasy fried
chicken and eat it with mashed potatoes
and macaroni and cheese before they get
on a plane and then they touch the plain
seeds with their greasy fingers but I
want everyone to have that experience I
don't want anyone to not have that
experience I want you to be able to take
your kids to laser tag I want your kids
to be able to get addicted to drugs I
want you to be able to put them in a
program I want you to be able to become
friends with a woman who runs that
program who's named Jennifer who's a
little fat who's an ex-alcoholic but
owns a bar and you go that doesn't
really make sense but whatever you know
the kids really like her and I want uh
you to drop your kids off at that
program every Wednesday and then I want
your son to tell you that he's really
excited because he has a month sober and
you're really proud of him and you go
out to a dinner and everybody's still
very anxious because it's only a month
sober but it's still really cool that he
did it you know and then fat Jennifer
the [__] weird ex alkie but still
owns a bar that runs the pro Ram is at
the dinner too and your son's 16 and
she's 28 and then eventually you know
you find out that Jennifer is pregnant
with your son's child okay and she's
gonna have his baby and instead of
putting her in jail you've researched
the consent laws and you decide to just
let it go you decide to actually let it
go you decide to let it go because you
think a baby actually might be a good
thing and it might keep your son on the
right track you decide to let it go you
decide to let the molestation of your
son at the hands of his drug counselor
go
and you have that baby and that baby is
very cute and it's very fat and it's
chubby and it doesn't know where it is
and you realize when you see that baby
that this is the promise of new life
this is the promise of America and this
is the greatness your 16 year old son
was molested by his drug counselor
Jennifer but he is sober now and he's
working construction but Rhonda Santos
is now instituted the e-verify in
Florida which means your son can no
longer work at the construction job he
comes home and he's upset you could
smell the beer on his breath the cerveza
and he's angry and you say son why or
why aren't you at work you have a baby
and your son goes because Ron DeSantis
um is enforcing e-verify which means I
need a social security number in order
to work and you're like [__] this is
[__] up [__] my undocumented son who's
molested by his drug counselor who had
this very cute little baby is working
every day at a construction site which
has now been shut down because Ron
DeSantis is instituted e-verify meaning
that my son cannot go to his
construction job for to pay for the baby
he had with his [__] drug counselor
who molested him
what a uniquely American situation
and then you start going well what can
my son do
what can your son do it's so hard right
he can't do anything official so listen
he starts moving a little bit of weight
he starts selling drugs and in the
beginning you judge him for it you judge
him for it because at the end of the day
you say [__] you know isn't there
anything else he can do but then he
starts bringing home some money then he
starts bringing home some money and then
there's a new crib and then he was able
to actually pay for a new bathroom for
you in your little house
and you're like wow this is kind of
amazing and you know at the end of the
day we have so much money now even if he
gets caught and locked up which God
forbid ideas meal you would never want
to happen even if he gets locked up you
still have enough money to care for that
little chubby baby that he got and his
wife comes around every now and then to
see the kid they're no longer together
which makes sense I mean these teacher
student things don't last but she comes
around and you've smacked her up a few
times she's a drunk and she comes there
all sloppy and drunk with her tits out
and you go listen you're lucky you're
not in jail you [__] rapist be the
fan and you say you go bid the fair in
that like Venezuelan accent
and she comes around to see the baby but
you let her see her baby and your son's
finally making good money selling drugs
because Ron DeSantis made him not a
construction worker and your son
actually says to you sometimes like yeah
you still [__] make the construction
now I'm the king I need to go actually
to be honest with you he's doing very
well and your son sells all of this
cocaine and he starts actually
you know just he's got this street team
of kids doing it for him and he's very
smart and he has this system where as
soon as anyone gets caught he kills them
so they don't rat on him he actually
kills him they're 13 they're 14. he
kills them all so they can't ride on him
and it's very heartless but people are
willing to take the chance because he's
paying them so much money he's paying
them an inordinate amount of money to do
this they get much higher percentages
than any Street Runner kids do but they
know they have the chance if they get
caught they get rocked and he uses
younger and younger children because
they evade the police so he's using 12
year olds and 13 year olds to sell Coke
and every now and then he has to kill
one of them and you kind of know this
because you've heard it from people but
you refuse to really look at the ins and
outs of his business because it doesn't
really matter you know and you remember
Coming to America and you remember you
know how hard it was and you're still
undocumented and you've been cleaning
toilets and [__] folding laundry and
you know how tough it is and all you
want is to have that American dream and
your son is ironically having that dream
by building a cocaine Empire okay and
he's working with white people now and
business owners he's laundering money
because they get involved too and you
know he's hanging out with political
people and then eventually he gets you
all citizenship your son gets you all
citizenship by being a cocaine dealer
and servicing very well because your son
also and I hate to say this I don't want
to say this the children that are
selling cocaine he's also pimping out to
high-end business uh people and
political leaders so your son is a human
trafficker as well now he's a human
trafficker and you hate the idea of that
but he's doing so well he's doing so
well he's a human trafficker and a Norco
trafficker and he's doing well though
but and he's getting respect right and
then he decides to run for Congress
your son decides to run for Congress and
you're so proud of him and you're crying
when you're and he gets elected of
course why not he's he's an undocumented
guy
became documented who went through the
process who fought his way up and you
know we people don't really know exactly
how he made his money but it's just
construction or real estate and
at the end of the day when you're
standing there when he first becomes a
congressman and he's done it on the
bodies of children on the bodies of
women on the bodies of the poor on the
bodies of families he's done it with
drugs he's done it with human
trafficking I want you to see when he
takes that photo and that that still
moment in time where he becomes a
congressman he's done it just like
everyone else has he's an American now
and so are you and I want you to have
that experience I do I want you to have
that experience
as someone who comes to our country I
want your son to have that chance
I you know what I don't know if it's
gonna work out like that but I want your
kid to have that chance of becoming a
drug dealer a human trafficker and then
a congressman
that's what I want because that is the
American [__] dream okay
that's what I want